[Música]
si quiere ver los manuscritos de Marie
Curie tendrá que firmar una exoneración
y ponerse equipo de protección para
protegerse de la contaminación por
radiación los restos de Madame Curie
fueron enterrados en un ataúd forrado de
plomo para mantener bien contenida la
radiación núcleo de su investigación Y
probablemente la causa de su muerte
originaria de Varsovia en la Polonia
ocupada por Rusia la joven Marie cuyo
nombre de soltera era Mary scrollska fue
una estudiante brillante pero enfrentó
barreras desafiantes como mujer se le
prohibió seguir estudios superiores Así
que en un acto de desafío morir se
matriculó en la floriding University
institución secreta que brindaba
estudios clandestinos a la juventud
polaca ahorrando dinero y trabajando
como institutriz y tutora finalmente
pudo mudarse a París para estudiar en la
sorbona allí Marie obtuvo un título en
física y matemáticas Sobreviviendo
principalmente con pan y té y
desmayándose por hambre en París conoció
al físico peer Curie quien compartió su
laboratorio y su corazón con ella pero
ella anhelaba volver a Polonia al
regresar a Varsovia encontró que lograr
una posición académica como mujer seguía
siendo un desafío no todo Estaba perdido
de vuelta en París el enamorado Pierre
la estaba esperando se casaron
rápidamente y se convirtieron en un gran
equipo científico
en 1896
descubrió que el uranio emitía
espontáneamente una Misteriosa radiación
similar a rayos x que podría interactuar
con una película fotográfica pronto
descubrió que el elemento torio emitía
una radiación similar lo más importante
la fuerza de la radiación dependía
únicamente de la cantidad del elemento y
no era afectado por cambios físicos o
químicos esto la llevó a concluir que la
radiación provenía de algo fundamental
dentro de los átomos de cada elemento la
idea era radical y ayudó a refutar el
Antiguo modelo de átomos como objetos
indivisibles luego al enfocarse en un
mineral súper radioactivo llamado
petchblanda los
uranio solo no podía crear toda la
radiación había otros elementos
radioactivos que podrían ser
responsables en 1898 informaron de dos
nuevos elementos polonio llamado así por
la Polonia natal de Mary y Radio la
palabra latina para radio también de
paso acuñaron el término radioactividad
en 1902 los curiouty extrajeron una
décima parte de gramo de sal de cloruro
de radio puro de varias toneladas de
pets una hazaña en ese momento ese año
[Música]
fueron nominados al Premio Nobel de
Física Pero Mary fue ignorada Pierre se
mantuvo firme en apoyo del merecido
reconocimiento de su esposa y así
compartieron el premio Nobel de 1903
convirtiendo a Marie Curie en la primera
mujer Premio Nobel bien financiados y
respetados los kury estaban en una buena
racha pero la tragedia ocurrió en 1906
cuando Pierre fue atropellado por un
carro tirado por caballos
se sumergió en su investigación y asumió
el puesto docente de Pierre en las
hormona y se convirtió en la primera
profesora de la universidad su trabajo
en solitario fue fructífero en 1911 ganó
otro novel esta vez en química por su
descubrimiento anterior de radio y
polonio y por su extracción y análisis
del radio puro y sus compuestos esto la
convirtió en la primera y hasta la fecha
única persona en ganar premios Nobel en
dos disciplinas diferentes
puso sus descubrimientos a trabajar y
cambió el panorama de la investigación
médica y sus tratamientos abrió unidades
de radiología durante la Primera Guerra
Mundial e investigó los efectos de la
radiación en los tumores Pero estos
beneficios pueden haber tenido un alto
costo personal kiwi murió en 1934 de una
enfermedad que muchos creen que fue
causada por su exposición a la radiación
la investigación Revolucionaria de sentó
las bases para nuestra comprensión de la
física y la química y caminos
fructíferos en oncología tecnología
medicina y física nuclear por nombrar
unos pocos para bien o para mal sus
descubrimientos en la radiación lanzaron
una nueva era y desenterraron algunos de
los mayores secretos de la ciencia
para conocer más historias de mujeres
que ayudaron a dar forma a La historia
ve a uno de estos videos y suscríbase a
nuestro canal
[Música]